[Music]
yep that's me I'm Ferdinand is like very
big your ginormous more of me to love
very strong you ready to put those wings
to work watch
oh no you shot Maria into the Sun sorry
family of pepper was the good boy but if
the world sees Ferdinand is one thing a
fighter I am here descended couple my
hunts for my instruments us are my arms
next test and by ducks no I'll pass
thanks you guys go ahead I know exactly
how Ferdinand feels let's go out there
and give it 110% actually I'm gonna pass
on the violence
you're finally ready to fight come on I
am NOT a fighting boy the movie sends a
message that resonates very strongly
with me
don't judge a bull by his cover there
are places out there where you don't get
pushed around for being yourself heads
for one and hog for everybody
[Music]
from the creators of Ice Age and wheel
I'm getting out of this place can you
just try to be a little more quiet the
door to freedom just do exactly what we
do exactly as we do
you
[Music]
[Applause]
we have a new tradition I'm sorry honor
it's my fault we don't have a family
tradition going door-to-door looking for
family traditions we make candy canes
together
sugar
cut down a tree and then you dress its
courts with candles
[Music]
nothing like taking your calls up once
in a while you know it
whoa gross that went right through me
[Music]
you
Romeo and Juliet are moving to a whole
new garden all clear
not quite perfect but it's ours think of
all the adventures were gonna have oh
man Katie that is just are you done a
minute the quiz
humans coming poses everyone they were
supposed to live happily ever after but
when their world is in danger
Julia the gnomes throw Cup there's only
one known to call and Sherlock knows
sworn protector of garden knows
you mean except for the one you
literally just broke
[Music]
those rooms are in terrible danger of
the director of Kung Fu Panda can't
anyone hear this but they're going to
smashes or tomorrow night or an
adventure we have to get across that
River you'll need a ship no
Sherlock
you've got a great unknown
lynnie our next clue is in the park get
directions quickly this follow the blue
line on the ground until you find the
giant red Suns MacAvoy and we blocked to
attila jeff for mary j blige and Johnny
Depp with original music by Elton John
and Bernie Taupin
they have to go undercover let's go to
forward hold
I said home forgive me I'd never been
the back end of a squirrel before
Sherlock knows that's not how a squirrel
six it's behind mankini can you
demonstrate you see what I'm doing
you see yes you're acting like a rear
end
[Music]
[Applause]
Oh generous honest pure graceful
creatures our natural rabbit space
should be able to keep up do you know
what that would never have worked
exactly no pants you must be Peter
Rabbit yeah that's right wait didn't you
try to eat me show me your teeth do you
like a go block it was you how are you
so good to see you
I don't think of one thing that could
stop our fun
you're coming hello this way
[Music]
new neighbor I'll explain it to him
we'll share our land around here hello
I'm Bea these gates are incredibly
sturdy I just need to keep the wildlife
out where they belong you're joking
right yes they're angels this is their
place okay so he's tricked up there's
only one way out of this he's got a go
do you know they set traps in my bed
he's a rabbit he wouldn't hurt anyone I
have a vermin problem an electric pencil
paper mail no mrs. tiggy-winkle stop
look away we can't give up it's our home
you're mine ribbit
what's going on yet wait - boys getting
alone
nothing could make me happier I got us
into this I'm gonna fix it
[Music]
[Applause]
which my mouse
[Music]
[Applause]
wait so how many of us have you
you
[Music]
[Applause]
you